[Music]
breaking tonight texas republican
governor greg
abbott issuing a disaster declaration
over the border crisis
it is the first such declaration from
abbott tonight we continue
our reporting on the dangerous criminals
encountering american law enforcement
along the border this evening
the harrowing pursuit of a smuggler
carrying more than a dozen illegal
immigrants
in a single vehicle correspondent asha
hosni reports from mission texas
a smashed up black suv covered in dirt
sits on the side of a highway
after rolling over during a high-speed
police chase
inside 17 migrants being smuggled into
the u.s
this is one of 300 vehicle pursuits
texas department of public safety
officers engaged in
since march in the rio grande valley but
smugglers aren't just moving people
check out this tick tock video given to
fox news by a law enforcement source
who says it appears to show multiple
drug smugglers
inside a vehicle cutting in and out of
traffic
while being chased by border patrol
[Applause]
meanwhile new details are coming out
about president biden's wide reaching
plans
to make it easier to enter the u.s the
new york times obtaining a blueprint
dated may 3rd
entitled dhs plan to restore trust
in our legal immigration system which
lists policy proposals like shorter
immigration forms and fewer security
checks
to help more foreigners move to the
united states including high-skilled
workers
trafficking victims the families of
americans living abroad
american indians born in canada refugees
asylum seekers
and farm workers essentially undoing
many
trump-era immigration policies former
acting ice director tom homan says
he saw this coming they're going to make
illegal immigration
legal they're going to change the asylum
rules because 90 percent of central
americans who claim asylum
never get relief from u.s courts because
they don't qualify so they're going to
change the rules and make it so they
qualify
and shannon the new disaster declaration
here in texas means the governor is now
sending in
more state and local resources to help
combat
the migrant surge shannon
hi shahassen hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else